un soir de césar depuis la jolie formule
de coluche on sait qu'il faut toujours
remercier claude berri ont le saluera
tout à l'heure mais je voudrais pouvoir
à montaut lui dire merci
et dire combien sa présence son regard a
compté pour moi
il va nous manquer il va me manquer le
cléac'h est attribué annie girardot dans
la tête de l'otan je ne sais pas si j'ai
manqué au cinéma français mais à moi le
cinéma français a manqué follement
éperdument douloureusement
et votre témoignage votre amour me font
penser que peut-être je dis bien
peut-être je suis pas encore tout à fait
morte
on m'a demandé de bien vouloir lui
remettre un césar d'honneur
j'ai accepté pourquoi pourquoi
parce que parce que cette année tu
aurais soixante dix ans et que tu me
manque terriblement
alors ce soir je voudrais vous demander
pour elle une chose simple mais ô
combien symbolique c'est de vous lever
pour ses 70 ans et de l'applaudir avec
moi
annie girardot
c'est très très heureuse mais le césar
de la meilleure actrice est attribué à
emmanuelle devos
vous n'avez pas de micro de ce côté là
j'ai pas fini ça c'est un message
personnel pour jacques audiard césar du
meilleur acteur dans un second rôle est
attribué un michael lonsdale
te voilà petit coquin
amis du temps là mieux vaut tard que
jamais isabelle adjani
je crois que je n'ai jamais été aussi
que ce soir pour pour ça
mélanie laurent mon anniversaire il ya
deux jours et c'est gentil d'y avoir
pensé c'est merveilleux tout ce qui
m'est arrivé est en fait le plus beau
dans tout ça c'est de le partager avec
celui quand même
alors julien les portois
le césar du meilleur espoir masculin est
attribué à tarime les mecs quelle
aventure quand même c'est extraordinaire
je pense que je serai jamais je vous
dirai jamais assez merci pour pour me
voir faire ça pour m'avoir invité à bord
jacques pour m'avoir mis en première
classe
le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué la môme marion pense que ce
césar vient récompenser une très grande
actrice et je crois savoir de pau sport
le césar du meilleur acteur est attribué
à tarime
joubert a remercié la france du cinéma
pour cet honneur et à et vive le cinéma
français
les césar est attribué à kad merad et
olivier del à olivier non j'ai besoin de
mon mari enfin mon ex mari mon ex mari
parce qu'avant de la paix merad je
m'appelle olivier donc voilà je vais le
saluer parce que sans mon ex mari je ne
serais pas ce soir avec vos furets quand
même dire deux trois mots en anglais
enfin voulait traduire des mots en
français je crois que je peux voler je
crois que je te peut toucher les nuages
à bérive à tout cela merci beaucoup